bueno buenos días a todos soy 'fan' y
soy soltera tengo 30 años y soy
directora desde muy chica sabía que lo
mío iba por lo audiovisual y de hecho
nunca se me ocurrió estudiar otra
carrera y a los 18 años decidí ir a
argentina a estudiar cine cine digital y
para para cine
agarré mis maletas me fui feliz a
argentina al principio todo bien pero
luego sentí la pegada me sentía sola
estaba deprimida también estaba cansada
porque trabajaba para poder pagar mis
estudios y hecho al principio me costó
muchísimo acostumbrarme pero bueno nadie
dijo que cumplir los sueños era fácil
después de unos años fui a méxico a
complementar mi carrera y ya con 22 años
decidí volver a perú a perú me dijo mi
mamá pero porque a perú quédate en
argentina o yate en méxico ahí la
industria del cine está muchísimo más
desarrollada y es cierto pero yo la
verdad que enseñaba muchísimo y quería
hacer una carrera acá entonces vine y
por suerte entré rápido a uno
que se llama banfield y entré como
editora de vídeos institucionales luego
me contrataron para ser parte de la
producción y luego ser parte del equipo
de guión finalmente para el área de
dirección de arte que era el área en la
cual yo me había especializado y después
de unos años me dijeron si yo estaba
preparada para hacer primera película yo
tenía 26 años y estaba feliz porque
siempre soñé con hacer una película
antes de los 27 porque no sé avión hasta
había escuchado que 227 es el punto
medio entre la juventud y la adultez y
de hecho mucha gente cambia su vida a
esa edad se casan tienen hijos cosa que
claramente a mí no me estaba pasando
pero sentía que era una buena edad para
poder tener un reto o cumplir un sueño
entonces acepté en la productora me
dieron carta libre para elegir el género
de la película y yo elegí suspenso
porque es mi género favorito y aparte
soy fan número uno de alfred
entonces comencé a hacer la película y
no de unos meses la grabé y de hecho fue
un proceso muy bacán porque era la
primera vez que yo hacía una película y
estaba súper feliz después de unos meses
construimos el tráiler de la película el
trainer es este vídeo sinopsis de la
película y se lo mostramos a la
distribuidora y la distribuidora lo vio
y dijo mira muy bonita la película y
todo pero es una película muy chica o
sea esto no vende va a ser muy muy pocos
espectadores es decir le va a ir muy muy
muy muy mal y yo me quedé así como que
haya seguro están exagerando la gente no
sabe
no sé puse muchas ideas en mi cabeza
pero para sorpresa mía tenían razones la
película fue un fracaso taquillero duró
una semana en cartelera y les juro que
fue la semana más difícil de mi vida en
la cual yo me hacía muchas preguntas
como si realmente había valido la pena
irme a estudiar fuera si era buena lo
que hacía comencé como que a
cuestionarme mucho
recuerda también que unos amigos me
decían oye pero porque mejor no vuelves
a la dirección de arte no es lo mejor
que te queda más cómodo quedarte
solamente en esa área que salga de
dirección no es lo tuyo y ese es un
momento súper duro porque de por sí es
muy difícil
cargar con tus propias inseguridades
pero a esas sumar en las inseguridad que
los demás tienes sobre ti es terrible
entonces claramente no me quedó más que
llorar y llorar y llorar pero bueno
gracias a dios estaba trabajando en una
productora en la que si confiaban y
luego de unos años me dijeron hoy ayer
sácate el clavo y haz una segunda
película y yo por supuesto la que no
confía en ese momento en mi era yo y me
dijeron mira haz una comedia en la cual
obviamente sea más amplia para el
público y yo dije pucha una comedia pero
qué difícil no sé qué voy a hablar así
que recordé que siempre hablaba con mi
hermana temas sobre desamor y la
soltería
entonces le conté la situación y me dijo
es perfecto esto va a ser un éxito hace
una película es una comedia femenina que
hable del amor propio pero yo la verdad
en ese momento no tenía fuerzas ni para
dirigir y mucho menos para escribir el
guión y ya me dijo no te preocupes yo te
ayudo mi hermana no es guionista no
estudió cine pero es una persona muy
chistosa entonces le hice caso y comencé
a escribir con ella pero me moría de
miedo y yo le decía no puedo me muero de
miedo ella me dijo mira
el miedo no se te va a ir a las cosas
con miedo pero hay más hay toro por las
astas me dijo y así fue
luego de unos meses de varios meses
termine de escribir el guión con ella
y tenía ya que buscar a la actriz
protagónica yo elegí a patricia barreto
que es una actriz excelente teatro es
brillante pero algunos me comenzaban a
decir es que no es muy famosa ojo que
quizá es un poco riesgoso poner a una
cara no conocida por el rol protagónico
pero en ese momento como que no le
presta atención y dije mira para mí es
perfecta y me dejaron hacerlo entonces
ya luego de unos meses tenía al elenco
perfecto al equipo técnico indicado que
de hecho yo obligué a cada jefe de área
a poner mujeres en el equipo y éramos un
montón de mujeres haciendo cine y esto
fue bacán porque cuando avanzamos juntas
avanzamos todas y os pareció perfecto
luego tenía la canción número 15 de
guión y el título perfecto para la
película se iba a llamar no me digas
solterona
después de unos meses gravera película
fue una experiencia súper bacán pero
para mí también fue súper enriquecedora
porque tuve que dirigir a 22 actores
dentro de los cuales estaba la primera
actriz mexicana angélica aragón con la
cual embarazo un lujo a trabajar y todo
venía bien hasta que después de unos
meses me tocó hacer el tráiler junto con
dos amigos hicimos el tráiler para mí
era perfecto era el tráiler que iba
perfecto con la película se lo mostramos
a la distribuidora
a varias no solamente una y todos
coincidían con que la película no vendía
que es un tema quedó muy bonito el amor
propio traga pero que eso no vende y que
solamente quizás sea para el público
femenino y para nada más yo decía pero
qué tan difícil puede ser vender una
película con un mensaje es tan bonito de
amor propio que no necesitamos a nadie
para ser feliz que el amor más grande es
el que uno puede sentir por uno mismo y
ahí entendí que cuando uno viene con
nuevas ideas es cuando quizás no recibe
un tú puedes no cuando uno intenta
romper el molde es cuando más trampas te
ponen a prueba te ponen y de hecho la
gente que me decía esto no era
cualquiera era gente especializada y de
hecho eran los responsables de varios
éxitos taquilleros en nuestro país y de
hecho la gente que sabía entonces yo me
comencé a preguntar mucho y si tienen
razón y si en verdad la película no es
lo que yo pienso que es
y muchas me equivoqué otra vez entonces
dije no sé es que si me volví a
equivocar ya sé que me equivoqué pues ya
fue pero yo no me daba por vencida antes
de luchar la batalla así que me sequé
las lágrimas y me vestí de valentía yo
nunca he sido una chica con brillo a mi
al colegio no me elegían y para cantar
ni para actuar en el miedo cosa
desapercibida yo soy la menor de tres
hermanos mi hermano mayor
siempre fue un cascabel super
histriónica y de hecho cuando jugábamos
a utilísima satelital ella era la
cocinera y yo era el camarógrafo
cuando jugaba con mi hermano él era
maradona y yo el arquero por supuesto
atajada todos los penales con mi cara
pero las atajadas
y siempre he sido muy tímida entonces
sabía que eso lo tenía que cambiar y que
me tenía que ver fuerte y decidida y de
hecho la industria del cine como
seguramente muchas industrias más no es
difícil ser joven y no es difícil ser
joven y es difícil ser mujer
de hecho las películas más taquilleras
peruanas habían sido escritas por
hombres protagonizadas por hombres
dirigidas por hombres y yo creo que ese
fue un poco el motivo por el cual
tampoco confiaron mucho mi proyecto a mí
me dijeron que cambiara el tráiler que
no que yo venda un tráiler de una
historia de chico conoce chica y
probablemente sean felices y yo decía
pero no porque eso sería quitarle el
propósito a mi proyecto y cuando algo tú
le quitas el propósito pierde el alma y
cuando pierde el alma no conecta con la
gente
en el fondo provee estas versiones que
ellos me decían yo creo que más que nada
para demostrarles a ellos que estaban
equivocados
luego de muchas conversaciones se quedó
en que el trailer que iba a salir
finalmente era el mío de la primera
opción que también debo admitir que
corregir algunas cosas que ellos me
dijeron y que finalmente era un mejor
tráiler yo estaba feliz porque había
quedado el mío y planteamos la fecha de
estreno del tráiler habíamos planteado
el 25 de diciembre que era como un
regalo de navidad hicimos toda una
campaña promocional hicimos una cuenta
regresiva y poníamos faltan cinco días
para el trailer faltan cuatro días
frente a groserías para entender 21 y
indulto lo recuerda
24 en la noche mire yo sé que todas las
pero nos la pasamos muy mal pero estoy
segura que la pasé peor que todos
ustedes juntos porque de nochebuena no
tuvo nada me la pasé hablando con la
productora con la distribuidora diciendo
por favor no podemos seccionarle trier
mañana no lo va a ver ni mi mamá
sáquenlo en una vez y por suerte
me hicieron caso pero lo sacamos el 27
por supuesto yo el 27 ya no tenía
muchos ánimos estaba recontra cada vez
baja y cuando salió estaba con un
compañero al costado y me dice oye ni
tienes mil vistas al tráiler 2000 vistas
al tráiler 3000 vistas y les juro que
habían pasado segundos y yo vivencia
muchas que buena onda mis compañeros
como él están dando en rifles a youtube
para hacerme sentir mejor pero las
vistas crecían y crecían y crecían y sin
saberlo al fin del día terminamos con un
millón de vistas y se convirtió en un
récord absoluto para la cantidad de
vistas en un trailer y ahí comenzaron a
cambiar las cosas que si bien yo no me
cruce de brazos ni el equipo tampoco al
contrario la productora de la
distribuidora y yo comenzamos a trabajar
más que nunca para sacar una película
que puse parecía un éxito pero para
ponerle mucha más energía
hicimos promociones concursos gráficas
miren que no hicimos luego de unos meses
ya estaba lista para que se lance la
película para el estreno también hicimos
una cuenta regresiva y faltaban tres
días para el estreno dos días para el
estreno un día para el estreno y
renuncia a ppk
yo me acuerdo que el elenco me llamaba y
me decía a mí la película no la estrené
él no la va a ver nadie el país está en
crisis pero por dios la que estábamos en
crisis era yo
y dije pero por qué por qué hasta que me
calme y dije es que voy a tomarlo como
un buen augurio sin noticias política
pasada tuvo muchas veces el trailer
esperaba que este caso la película
también tenga muchas citas asistencia al
cine y la escuela que comenzar a rezar a
todos los santos y no les miento y mi
mamá no dejar de mentir porque en mi
casa parecía santuario de todas las
velas misión de las que habíamos
comprado mi paseo se agotó las velas de
la bodega y todo y por suerte fue todo
un éxito
el estreno asistieron 53 mil personas
quedamos número uno en el ranking no
solamente ese día sino que las semanas
siguientes
y me comenzaron a llegar mensajes super
bonitos no solamente a mujeres sino
también de hombres agradeciendo el
mensaje que tenía la película era como
que distinto a lo que se venía haciendo
y estaba súper feliz y sin darme cuenta
sin planearlo y sin imaginarlo me
convertí en la directora mujer más
taquillera del cine peruano
muchas gracias
y eso es algo que vi no sólo vino como
consecuencia del trabajo que hicimos
pero es un título que yo ni siquiera sé
de que existía lo que simplemente quería
hacer una película y tuve la suerte
también de trabajar con un equipo grande
con el cual estuvo trabajando muy arduo
conmigo y no me queda más que
agradecerles sin embargo bueno
la película duró tres meses en cartelera
un récord y recuerdo que algunas
personas se me acercaban y me decían oye
qué suerte que tuviste con tu película
no me digas ver todas
es
y hoy sea suerte yo creo que las
personas que vemos la luz al final del
túnel es porque tenemos suerte ni porque
tenemos talento porque yo no me
considero ni la mejor cineasta ni la
mejor guionista ni mucho menos la mejor
directora simplemente hoy me considero
una persona que supo luchar por lo que
quería no bajar los brazos nunca y que
gracias a dios estuvo al lado de un
equipo que si bien al principio lo
confiaba mucho luego sí lo hizo y yo
creo que cuando uno lidera un equipo
tiene que escuchar una sola voz y esa
voz es la de tu corazón porque eso se
llama intuición bobo
luego me tocó aprender algo que aunque
no crea un fe lo más difícil que me tocó
aprender con la película y fue el
aprender a reconocerme el éxito yo
recuerdo que al principio cuando estaba
cabizbaja la gente me decía oye sube el
ánimo no todo va a ser como tu primera
película y después cuando estaba más
contenta la gente me decía oye cuidado
no festejar antes de tiempo entonces yo
no sabía qué hacer y decidir bloquear
mis emociones y los tres meses que mi
película está en cartelera yo no les
dije hasta que me junte con una amiga y
me dijo pero qué haces acá anda wow
comete un champán y festeja
y yo creo que después de todo y ya para
finalizar creo que la lección más grande
que te deja una batalla es estar
orgulloso de haberla luchado
la vida no es para ser ganador ni ser
perdedor la vida es para ser nosotros
mismos y luchar la siempre aunque te
digas que no puedes yo hoy creo que sigo
siendo la misma chica de siempre demente
apasionada soñadora pero mucho más
fuerte y mucho más valiente y que no le
permite a nadie que me diga que no puedo
muchas gracias